last time you were here I see you talked
to you you talked about playing video
games and how you love to play video
games and you said that when you win you
you want to go back to that store you
you said you said you celebrate by
jumping up and doing something called
the dick dance you got a dick down want
me to re-explain it to this audience
what they think they get it yeah then
you win
when you win you know you play that
level and you win you finally get
through and you're so excited you just
pull out your dick you gotta be a gamer
to understand the excitement of beating
the level so much you got to do dance
though yeah I don't do it with the
homies over don't think I didn't say
anything I don't imagine when everyone's
watching football either yeah ATM you
jump up and do that too you keep that at
home and that's just for the two of you
yeah what do you do to celebrate if
there's something well I mean you know
what I do the boob dance but I mean the
thing is like I thought everybody did
the boob dance does anybody know how to
it like oh my god get in there oh my
[Applause]
to do that
who's in there for God's sake
what did some boob implants in there
she's moving them some average I mean I
don't even know how you get the muscle
to that's okay all right okay all right
[Laughter]
[Applause]
four million people hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos